[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic la relativité générale
qu'est ce que la gravitation la
gravitation ou gravité est un phénomène
fondamental dans l'univers qui tend à
unir les objets entre eux si la pomme
tombe au sol que la lune tourne autour
de la terre et que la terre tourne
autour du soleil
c'est à cause de la gravité qui lie ces
objets entre eux les empêchant de trop
s'éloigner les uns des autres
à première vue on pourrait penser que la
gravitation est une force qui agit en
attirant les objets en fonction de leur
masse plus un corps serait massif plus
il attirerait les autres objets de
l'univers dans sa direction
cette représentation de la gravité comme
une force permet de comprendre le
comportement des objets lorsqu'ils
tombent ou encore la façon dont les
planètes en orbite autour du soleil
mais en réalité certains indices subtils
indique que la gravitation n'est pas
vraiment une force
par exemple lorsqu'on observe un
satellite en train de tomber sur terre
si la gravité était une force
il devrait tomber tout droit vers le
centre de la planète
mais quand on fait l'expérience on
observe que sa trajectoire est très
légèrement dévié sur le côté dont le
sens de rotation de la terre autre
indice l'orbité de mercure change
d'orientation au cours du temps avec une
certaine vitesse
si la gravité était une force on sait
prédire avec exactitude la vitesse à
laquelle devrait évoluer cette orbite
mais dans les faits on observe que
l'orbité de mercure varie au cours du
temps avec une vitesse légèrement
différente
si on s'intéresse à prendre en compte
ces petites subtilités
on s'aperçoit finalement que la nature
de la gravitation est tout autre qu une
simple force la cerner nécessite de
revoir entièrement notre vision du monde
de l'univers tout entier ainsi que de
l'espace et du temps
c'est ce qu'on appelle la relativité
générale pour se construire la
relativité générale se basent presque
entièrement sur un principe fondateur le
principe d'équivalence le principe
d'équivalence postule que tous les
objets tombent de la même façon il dit
que la chute libre n'est pas l'action
d'une force que ce n'est pas un
mouvement accéléré de l'objet en train
de tomber mais qu'au contraire la chute
libre est le mouvement naturel des corps
lorsque des objets tombent sur terre la
situation revient à dire que ces objets
sont en fait au repos et que c'est en
réalité le seul qui accélère dans leur
direction
contrairement à notre intuition naïve
c'est le fait de tomber qui constitue un
mouvement naturel un mouvement de repos
tandis que le fait de rester immobile à
la surface de la terre revient en
réalité à s'opposer constamment à sa
chute à exercer sans cesse une
accélération vers le haut
c'est d'ailleurs pour cette raison qu'on
ne ressent notre poids qu'au moment de
toucher le sol pendant une chute libre
notre corps suit son mouvement naturel
et ce n'est qu'au contact du sol qu'on
ressent notre poids cette action dans
nos pieds qui vient s'opposer à la chute
relativité générale la gravitation n'est
donc plus une force on pourrait presque
dire que la gravitation n'existe pas ou
tout du moins que c'est une illusion
si les corps nous donnent l'impression
qu'ils tombent et qu'il s'attire entre
eux c'est parce qu'ils se déplacent de
façon naturelle repos mais dans un
univers à la géométrie en courbes et les
corps ne s'attire pas entre eux ils ne
font que se déplacer en ligne droite
mais de par leur masse il courbe
l'espace-temps autour d'eux ce qui
influence les trajectoires des autres
objets
l'idée la plus importante de la
relativité générale et que tous les
corps qui possède une masse déforme
l'espace temps autour d'eux pour
comprendre si on imagine notre univers
comme un immense réseau une grille d
espace et de temps un objet massif va
avoir pour effet de déformer cet espace
temps autour de lui les notions de
distance de direction ou encore
d'écoulement du temps sont ainsi
perturbé altérée par la présence de
l'objet de façon naturelle
un corps va avoir tendance à se déplacer
en ligne droite
par exemple si on lance une pomme au
beau milieu du vide intergalactique
elle va continuer sa trajectoire en
ligne droite toujours à la même vitesse
melançon maintenant cette même pomme à
proximité d'un objet massif comme la
terre comme elle est très massives la
terre des formes l'espace et le temps
autour d'elle les lignes droites sont
désormais distordue elle se courbe et
s'entremêlent en direction de la planète
ainsi quand on lâche la pomme elle va
partir en ligne droite mais comme les
lignes droites ont été déformés par la
masse de la terre la pomme va
progressivement se rapprocher du sol
c'est cet effet qu on appelle la
gravitation
lorsqu'un corps et très massif il
déforme la structure même de l'univers
autour de lui courbant les lignes
droites dans sa direction et par
conséquent tous les objets qui
l'entourent vont avoir tendance à suivre
ces lignes courbées et à se rapprocher
de l'objet pour mieux comprendre
imaginons un parallèle les deux
situations suivantes
d'une part deux observateurs se déplace
dans ligne droite vers le haut à la
surface d'un plan c'est à dire une
surface non courbet
d'autre part les deux observateurs se
déplace en ligne droite en direction du
nord
mais à la surface de la terre qui est
une sphère est donc cette fois ci une
surface courbet dans la première
situation pour la surface n'ont courbé
les deux observateurs vont se déplacer
en ligne droite de manière parallèle ils
ne vont de cette façon jamais se
rapprochés l'un de l'autre mais dans la
deuxième situation à la surface de la
terre en marchant tout droit nos deux
observateurs vont bizarrement finir par
se rejoindre au moment d'atteindre le
pôle nord
bien que chacun d'eux est marché
parfaitement en ligne droite
un pied devant l'autre du fait que la
terre est courbé et par conséquent que
le lignes droites sont déformés à sa
surface
les deux personnes ont eu l'impression
qu'une force mystérieuse les attirer les
obligeant progressivement à se rejoindre
avec cet exemple on comprend mieux
comment le phénomène de gravitation peut
émerger à partir de la courbure de
l'espace temps les objets semble
s'attirer entre eux leurs trajectoires
semblent se rejoindre progressivement
mais en réalité ce phénomène est dû à la
courbure des lignes droites le long
desquelles se déplacent les astres pour
illustrer les différents phénomènes
étranges qui apparaît ce temps
relativité générale
intéressons-nous un objet fascinant de
l'univers
le trou noir un trou noir est un objet
massif dont toute la matière est
principalement concentrée en un seul
point
on appelle ce point central
singularité gravitationnelle à cet
endroit précis de l'univers le tissu
d'espace-temps et distordu à l'infini et
la science moderne ne s'est toujours pas
décrire ce qui s'y passe à proximité de
la singularité la courbure de l'espace
temps est si intense que toutes les
lignes droites pointe dans cette
direction ici aucun objet ne peut
espérer s'échapper du trou noir
même pour un rayon lumineux toutes les
trajectoires possibles mène directement
vers la singularité le trou noir n'émet
pas de lumière et aucune matière ni
rayonnement ne peut s'en échapper
pour cette raison on le voit comme une
sphère complètement noir à l'extérieur
de cette zone de capture
au-delà de cette frontière qu'on appelle
son horizon
le trou noir se comporte à peu près
comme n'importe quel astres lorsqu'on se
trouve à proximité de l'horizon il est
impossible de rester en orbite stable
autour du trou noir
la déformation de l'espace temps est
trop prononcé ce qui rend les
trajectoires des objets chaotique est
difficile à prédire
à cette distance mais dès lors qu'on se
trouve suffisamment loin de l'horizon
comme dans le cas d'une planète où d'une
étoile
il est possible de gravité de façon
stable autour d'un trou noir est un
objet passant à proximité sera
légèrement déviée mais pourra tout de
même s'échapper de son attraction en
particulier les rayons lumineux qui
proviennent des étoiles lointaines vont
bifurquer au moment de passer à
proximité du trou noir pour cette raison
si on observe le trou noir de face on
peut voir une image déformée des étoiles
lointaines qui se trouve en arrière-plan
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'effet de
lentille gravitationnelle
un autre phénomène intéressant apparaît
lorsque le trou noir tourne sur lui même
dans le cas d'un trou noir en rotation
très rapide celui ci entraîne légèrement
le tissu de l'espace temps dans sa
rotation un objet qui tombe en direction
du trou noir
parcourant ainsi une ligne droite
courbet sera légèrement déviée dans le
sens de rotation de l'astre cet effet
très étrange s'applique d'ailleurs
également pour la terre dont la rotation
sur elle-même entraîne très légèrement
la chute des corps à sa surface
enfin l'un des phénomènes les plus
notables est ce qu'on appelle la
dilatation gravitationnelle du temps
lorsqu'on se trouve à proximité d'un
objet massif comme un trou noir
les lignes droites que l'on va suivre
sont non seulement des formes et dans
l'espace mais également dans le temps
l'écoulement du temps va être altérées
en fonction de la distance à laquelle on
se trouve d'un objet massif à grande
distance du trou noir
là où la courbure de l'espace-temps est
négligeable le temps s'écoule à peu près
comme n'importe où ailleurs
mais plus on se rapproche du trou noir
plus on va ressentir que le temps
s'écoule lentement à proximité de
l'horizon du trou noir
l'espace temps est tellement d'efforts
mais qu'il est possible que chaque
seconde qui s'écoule pour nous prennent
en réalité une année entière pour
s'écouler
du point de vue d'un observateur
lointain dans le cas général plus on se
trouve à proximité d'une source de
gravitation
c'est à dire d'un objet massif comme le
soleil ou la terre plus notre temps va
s'écouler lentement à la surface de la
terre par exemple si on compare les
horloges de deux personnes l'une se
trouvant au pied et l'autre au sommet de
la tour eiffel l'horloge de la personne
en bas va tourner légèrement moins vite
car elles se trouvent plus proche du
centre de la terre typiquement pour
chaque année qui s'écoule la personne
aux pieds de la tour aura vieilli d'une
micro secondes en moins que la personne
au sommet de la tour
cet effet de dilatation des durées et
très subtil mais très importants sur
terre il est notamment central 2
prendre en compte lors de la conception
des satellites gps de sorte à assurer la
synchronisation de leur horloge interne
pour résumer la relativité générale
donne un cadre de compréhension pour
cerner la nature même de ce qu'est la
gravitation
lorsqu'un objet massif repose dans
l'espace temps il déforme sa géométrie
autour de lui courbant les lignes
droites dans l'espace et dans le temps
ce qui a pour effet de dévier la
trajectoire des objets environnants et
de modifier leur perception du temps
outre la gravitation la relativité
générale entraîne également une quantité
d'autres conséquences étonnantes
l'une de ses conséquences par exemple et
que l'espace temps ne se déforme pas de
façon instantanée à la manière d'un
tissu que l'on viendrait perturber
si un objet apparaît de nulle part son
influence gravitationnelle va mettre un
certain temps pour se propager
progressivement à travers l'espace et le
temps
pour ben la géométrie de l'univers au
fur et à mesure de sa progression et ce
à la vitesse de la lumière
cette particularité entraîne l'existence
des ondes gravitationnelles
c'est à dire des phénomènes de
distorsion de l'espace et du temps qui
se propage à travers l'univers à la
vitesse de la lumière
ces ondes gravitationnelles sont générés
à des années lumière de la terre par des
événements cataclysmiques
par exemple la fusion de deux trous
noirs elles viennent nous traverser
régulièrement déformant légèrement notre
planète et tout ce qui s'y trouve sous
leur passage enfin
cette idée que notre univers puisse
présenter une géométrie distordue pose
la question de sa forme à grande échelle
et incite à de nombreuses imagination
comme l'existence possible de raccourcis
géométriques à travers l'espace et le
temps
encore très spéculatif à ce jour c'est
ce qu'on appelle les trous de faire
[Musique]